have we started to see within the past
year perhaps that magnus sometimes
getting too pragmatic in the ending
i mean i think his endings are still i
mean the best there's ever been and
i i i mean i'm surprised he didn't win
this one i mean what do you think david
i mean he's too pragmatic or yeah i
think just struggling to calculate as
deeply as he maybe is used to and now
here we go the black pawn is just too
close to its promotions where white's
king is cut off as well white king it's
going to try and come back but the black
king is going to shoulder it off and by
shouldering we mean the black king will
kind of block the white king from going
towards this black pawn and
this one is dead draw now the black pawn
just pushes forward
if this position with white to play
white would be winning but nope the
black king
is just in time and
here we go we're about to see a draw
yeah king versus king
no way to win this game magnus shaking
his head and there we go draw yeah
well done by you